we are now in the midst of the longest
shutdown of the federal government in
history at the stroke of midnight the
shutdown entered its 22nd day with no
apparent end in sight Congress and
President Trump are at an impasse over
funding for a wall at the southern
border a CBS News poll finds 55% of
Americans disapprove of the president's
actions over the shutdown 43 percent
disapprove of the job congressional
Democrats are doing to end it
while 53 percent don't like how
Republicans in Congress are handling the
situation Kenneth Craig has the latest
on this record shutdown Kenneth no one
seems happy right now good morning good
morning to you Dana President Trump has
walked back his vow to declare a
national emergency if he has to in order
to get his wall with most lawmakers at
home for the weekend negotiations
between the White House and
congressional Democrats have fallen
apart with no new talks or plans in
sight no I said I could do it but it's
the easy way out
president Trump Friday backed away from
his earlier insistence on declaring a
national emergency to get his border
wall this is something that Congress
should easily do this is something that
the Democrats should do but just a day
earlier if we don't make a deal I would
say it would be very surprising to me
that I would not declare a national
emergency
on Friday he doubled down on Democrats
to fund his wall they could name it
whatever they can name it Peach's I
don't care what they name it
but we need money
a CBS News poll found that 47% of
Americans say they blame President Trump
for the partial government shutdown 30%
say they blame Democrats in Congress and
just three percent blame Republicans we
have a country that's being invaded by
criminals and by drugs
a majority of Americans 55 percent of
them believe the situation on the
southern border is a problem not a
crisis a growing number of Republicans
are expressing concern at the president
trying to bypass Congress I think that
there's a fair amount of the question as
to whether or not he does have that
roads
of authorities meanwhile federal workers
wait to get paid federal employees are
bearing the brunt of something on their
back for a policy initiative really we
don't have anything many of them agree
with what I'm saying and I appreciate
their incredible support before they
left Washington Congress passed
legislation to ensure that federal
workers receive back pay the president
says he will sign that bill but until he
and Democrats reach a deal it's unclear
when federal employees will get that
paycheck Anthony Kenneth thanks very
much